without like the University diploma that
you're going to end up buying painful
retail for is going to get you your gig
necessarily we're taught in the system
that failure is something that you
should be ashamed of failure is for the
dumb kids you know the minute you feel
like you've arrived as a minute you you
know you soften up hello believe nation
I'm Evan Carmichael my one word is
believe and I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the major
problems of the world so to help you on
your journey today we're going to learn
from fashion designer Marc Ecko and my
take on this top ten rules for success
rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the best and as always guys did
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well
enjoy
how many of you guys hands show of hands
how many of you folks here have a goal
alright you sure you sure yet we'll keep
your hands up and stay up are you sure
you have a goal now keep your hands up
if you could believe you could realize
that goal no matter what twists and
turns come in your life anyone a little
trepidation I see some hands coming down
for those that have kept their hands up
you are all entrepreneurs alright give
yourself a hand and that's what it's
going to take and I don't be like
entrepreneur get your mouth around that
word entrepreneur what does that mean
don't be a regular entrepreneur be a
beast okay get it done just know you got
a like the opportunity now to kind of be
industrious and what's gating us there
are no limitations as to what's gating
us right
there's so many efficiencies now built
into media technology and broadcasting
publishing portraying yourself
visualizing yourself as a brand yourself
independently right that shame on you
for not trying and making something out
of it like that's the window we live in
right now it sound like the schools are
going to figure it out right not like
days University diploma that you're
going to end up buying painful retail
for is going to get you your gig
necessarily right so the window to kind
of like capture the hustle and to do
something with it on your terms it is a
really exciting time right now needless
to say in 93 I dropped out of college
started my business and it occurred to
me that I was going to be very average
at pharmacology and I was going to be
something above average when I was
working on what I loved which was
painting and creating and that
at finding that pearl that passion point
to build your business around it there's
it's so cliche you know people talk
about passion but you know with all the
ups and downs of running a business and
creating a business and the
uncertainties markets and you know you
arrive at the gates of success and I
remember thinking I'll be rich young
when you know you arrive at a place
where you would think that that would
suffice like a true entrepreneur someone
who is someone who wants to discover
what's next
someone who has to be working on what
they love will not be satiated or
satisfied with just the money it's not
enough it's the learning that comes to
doing what you love and for me you know
that's been the blessing and the good
fortune what I've had I think the best
advice that I could give you on success
is to know that success is merely the
hangover or failure and that failure is
an essential ingredient in creating a
learning atmosphere for you so that you
can accrue those learnings the small
incremental steps of failure and collect
enough learning so that you can arrive
at success right I think we're taught in
the system that failure is something
that you should be ashamed of failure is
for the dumb kids because you can f you
get a D right you're not competent you
didn't comply you didn't create the
evidence of your worthiness but I can
tell you someone who's successful right
both financially and from a wealth
creation point of view but more
importantly a wealth that matters that
success doesn't look like an a-plus it
doesn't look like a hundred and ten and
extra credit and failure isn't as simple
as an F it's not always Kellis like
failure could be very gray right and
being able to discern what you might
arrive at
then or in your life where you think
that wow I've succeeded and you're
getting the affirmation from all these
outside forces but if it's not aligned
authentically with to whom which you are
it could very much feel like failure
you're going to fail it's okay
okay you're going to fail and I'm not
talking about the test it's one thing
talking about to your knees your skin
bloody fail and that's okay because you
know what you know down deep inside all
of you that's how you learn you need to
be motivated by failure how'd you learn
how to walk you crawled and you fell
down busted your tooth got some blood in
your mouth get up and you walk right
self-directed I wonder why it was a
rhino of the logo why the Rhino um it
was one of those manna from the heaven
things you know three years into the
business I was at a trade show and all
my competitors had kind of the same logo
everyone was using like a graffiti word
mark and I just felt like well how am I
going to differentiate myself from you
know the rest of the pack and I went
back to my home in Lakewood New Jersey
where I grew up and that was the spot
ease to airbrush you know t-shirts out
of my garage and right off of the room
where I would airbrush my dad had a
collection of little wood sand drift
rhinos are probably $2 a piece or
whatever and I just started a riff on it
and you know I brought it to the market
one piece at a time and I remember the
buyers were like we don't know about
that dinosaur we don't know about that
hippopotamus and they're like they're
like give me more graffiti t-shirt to my
guy but you know I want I want to
establish a logo like like polo or you
know Nike or Timberland and they weren't
really trying to feel that and you know
just staying persistent and it kind of
started to stick so one teacher became
three became five became you know the
the logo and but like logos are like
guns without ammo so it was really what
we did with it I think that that made it
more meaningful
husband it's all about you like I said
like never get high on your own supply
right when it's all about you you know
like biggie says actually right or
actually Scarface if you go back all the
way to the original reference but you
know that you can't think that like
you're the only game in town that's a
really dangerous thought process man you
know collaboration is good and it's
healthy and working with young cats that
are coming up and they have their own
revenge fantasies yo we could learn from
that I'm not too old to learn man I've
been going to school soon I might not
have been in the classroom but schools
come to me when you want to learn the
school comes to you so and I am content
being a student or you've had a lot of
success with complex in a very short
period of time when did you start it
well it's not really that short that's
what's interesting it's like 15 almost
took you 15 years to become an overnight
success Agassi and mm there's no such
thing as overnight yeah my the wait time
I see this all the time this is one of
the biggest American lie told ya
overnight success yeah it's a fallacy
now I'm always auditioning yeah you know
always don't new like it's always new
you know it's and you you know the
minute you feel like you've arrived is a
minute you you know you soften up and
you can't this I've had enough
experiences in my career ups down
sideways right and stay on that track
and I think you know that's why I'm at
now am I you know profession I think
both of us are like we're just like
let's just go get it full steam ahead
the first decade in my career I think I
got more value out of that that kind of
affirmation of being above average with
my hands and with my creativity then you
know then the actual cash I collected I
reflect back on it I probably wanting to
see whatever well no I I made good money
but it's funny like it's even a 41 today
there's that line that says mania it's
like a line of madness that is just it's
AIT's you in a way that just the
transactional side of collecting stuff
right filling your house up or more
stuff more you know it fills you in a
way that just pursuing the money can't
when you create wealth there's like you
could just create wealth or you can
create wealth that matters and I and
I've made a distinction in my life that
that's very important to me and when I
take an inventory of the things that
I've done they are can necessarily
measure them in finite numbers of
success of like dollars right that you
can't they some of the most impactful
things you can't necessarily measure
with a dollar amount it's more
qualitative right it's more like didn't
your stomach right it's like a feeling
thing and and they're there you know
there's certainly things I've done that
I'm really proud of that that probably
excite me more than any material stuff
for me inspiration is a is a journey it
is not a destination
okay it is a self you know motivated
internally motivated process it's not
this glamorous thing it is mundane it is
not something that just because you
arrive at the gates of success that
somehow has a new experience it's
different than when you were not not
successful it is exactly the same I find
inspiration on blank pages
I found inspiration you know in my
habits okay a moment of quiet that
intimacy on a heavy bag alone sweating
you know if it's me and a kettlebell or
me taking a walk and just breathing in
okay literally breathing in I'm able to
harvest inspiration I created a formula
that I want to share for him not much
much for math but this is the idea of a
unique voice when you transform when you
shed your skin the important thing to
hold on to is your voice what have I
done what am I most proud of in life
besides my kids I'm the most proud of
realizing and
listening to despite all the voices my
own voice and and trying to craft the
unique voice I say that it's what you do
it's action - fear okay / yourself how
selfish or selfless are you this is the
idea of unique voice try to break it
down for you very simply if you're
fearful we know being fearful sucks I
mean it immobilizes you it arrests you
from expressing yourself right now being
completely fearless you could be
reckless but fear with purpose write to
yourself - your voice is meaningful and
that's when you know real unique voices
are emerge it's not much not enough to
just talk right like someone like oddly
he didn't just talk you tell you
something doing and talking two
different things
action is the great equalizer okay we
live at a time there's so much noise so
much chatter in the system people just
you know a lot of people were really
fearless ideas but they don't act on it
right that's the dilemma and when you
act on it you become a unique voice
those are the voices they make monuments
to self well you could either be really
selfless like Gandhi who's like one in a
gazillion right like completely selfless
or really selfish that even when you got
everybody telling you everything you
want to hear you still won't listen to
anyone but yourself that's the worst
type to be but there's some balance
itself there is a degree of selfishness
that you have to kind of get to to
filter the noise and establish your
unique voice so you know this is the
unique voices of a generation right this
is how unique voices emerge young young
boys that sell more records than you
know Elvis right people that change the
world
that's what unique voices are about man
saying like Kanye and ade both two great
guys from Illinois right so I challenge
all of
you each and every one of you from the
inside out guts to the skin to the tape
to the denture glue right figure out
your unique voice nurture it
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because effect asked me
to so there's a famous entrepreneur that
you would like me to cover next check
out the link in the description and go
and cast your vote I also want to give a
quick shout out to telly Quinton from
you and Kelly Q comm Kelly thank you so
much for picking up ten copies of my
book and giving it to your friends I
really appreciate the support and I'm
glad that you enjoyed the read so thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
I am a brand I say you are a brand if
you like it or not if you know it or not
you know that some people are
uncomfortable with that like if you two
guys you know if M being Charlemagne or
like Angela and Andy if you guys went to
lunches let's talk about our personal
brands you probably would vomit on each
other right because it's such a like a
sappy learning it seems so like
patronizing to think about it but there
is a best practice of like being honest
and saying all right well let me take an
honest inventory guts to the skin of
what I'm composed of and is everything
that I'm working on reflect that because
that is your personal brand we've built
like an entrepreneurial ecosystem there
that's really empowered a lot of
independent thought leaders either video
production or in blogging or in fashion
and in independent music and for me
looking at that pipe the pipe that that
serves a lot of this content and it's
kind of it's it's kind of pursuit of
excellence because it's very easy to
have gone the cheap route on it and we
didn't took the hard route I think
that's one of the great achievements
somehow we think this notion of artist
or creator culturally in plot is an
indulgent notion it's would
self-indulgent self sillas optical
people that kind of get to dress in all
black and lean back and you know that
get to be Moody and self-loathing right
this is that we're sloppy right um that
we don't necessarily have the you know
we're right brain right brain artists
right brain don't give them a
spreadsheet or it's just not for you
right because as you get older maybe you
lose perhaps some of that swag or that's
freedom that when you were in second
grade where you just would raise your
hand you know and say yes I am fact an
artist we also think that this notion of
creator and artist is divine right
there's some divine thing like this you
know the famous Michelangelo image and
then we struggle in commercializing it
so we think that there's a holy war but
between creative and
art and commerce and this inhibits our
ability in our relationship with our art
right so I challenge folks who perhaps
don't necessarily fancy themselves
artists just because you can't
manipulate paint or sculpture music
doesn't mean that you shouldn't
problem-solve like an artist that you
have to learn to in breath embrace the
messiness of creation embrace the mess
you know problem-solve like an artist
give yourself more than 1%